mercredi coup de théâtre jacques borel
le napoléon de l'hôtellerie et de la
restauration
l'homme qui a mis la france à l'heure du
wimpy quitte la présidence de son
entreprise
al'annonce de cette nouvelle surprenante
et milliers de parisiens sont frappés de
stupeur le chagrin se lit sur leur
visage
jacques morel l'homme à qui l'on doit
les mille et un délices de nos
restaurants d'entreprise le mozart de
nos cantines scolaires les estomacs
français se souviendront longtemps de
lui sans aigreur né à perros guirec le
jeune jacques borel vécu ses jeunes
années dans les jupes de sa mère
doué il entra très tôt dans l'armée son
sens aigu du commandement son autorité
lui permirent de gravir rapidement les
échelons lieutenant puis commandant en
chef
remarque à tout de suite chez lui cet
esprit d'initiative
libéré de ses obligations militaires il
ouvrit une crêperie bretonne automatique
ou durant des années ils s'activent à au
pliage de ces délicieuses pâtisseries
bretonnes
mettant à profit ses loisirs jacques
borel parcourt les routes de france et
s'aperçoit qu'elle manque singulièrement
de restaurants aussi décide-t-il de voué
sa vie à la restauration routière c'est
à jacques borel que nous devons les
fameuses oranges givré véritable régal
de nos restaurants d'entreprise
c'est à lui que nous devons également la
trieuse automatique de lentilles
véritable révolution culinaire les
bonnes lentilles tombe dans la casserole
les mauvaises sont jeté aux égouts
jacques borel met alors au point son
célèbre wimpy peser soigneusement il
reçoit alors le level de la marque
jacques aurel c'est en souvenir de tous
et mérite que la lorgnette était venu
déposer une gerbe au pied du monument
élevé à la mémoire du mangeur de wimbee
inconnu
le wimpy se régale de l'estomac le wimpy
ce sommet culinaire français jacques
borel
les français ne vous oublierons pas et
cette stèle qui rappelle vos débuts dans
la restauration
ce premier wimpy des de votre cru elle
restera longtemps gravé dans nos coeurs
à bientôt morel à dubaï nous t'aimer
bien c'est dur de mourir dawim bi-gpu
serais tu peux partir à la re fait la
paix dans l'âme
regarde bien ce qu elle non
[Rires]
au bas
pour voir barrel roll
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]